[Music]
what is up everybody welcome to stick to
football live the same six football used
to just now live in the Bleacher Report
app Matt Miller Melo and Connor Rodgers
new update on everything NFL Draft er
later we have a fun show for you guys
today we actually made up our own over
and unders for some of the most
polarizing players in this year's draft
class oh and also we're gonna give you
our dream I'll be a little bit realistic
landing spots for some of our favorite
players in this year's class as well but
fellas off the top congratulations to us
for getting a show in the bleach report
app but also congrats to Connors twin
brother Christian McCaffrey for a year
16 million per year buddy we're proud of
proud of your genetic big brother yeah
did we get the split knee of that money
that's what I'm wondering right now but
in all seriousness this is something we
talked about running back contracts on
this show all the time I actually like
that they were aggressive to get this
one out in front guys I mean the guy is
23 years old the deal will pay him till
he can you know it's ending his prime
for running back 27 28 this is really
exciting news for the Panthers in
McCaffrey yeah hey Connor I get to split
half of my contract it seems like with
my ex-wife so I think you could work
something out there to get a little
kickback for you but I do like what the
Panthers are doing they probably have
the best running back in the NFL right
now he's a do-it-all guy and at the end
of this four years if he can't run the
ball anymore I bet he can still catch
the ball just put him a slot receiver so
I saw people on Twitter say the NFL's
highest-paid slot receiver now Chris
Machamer 16 million a year we'll see if
he beats the odds as a second contract
running back we haven't seen a lot of
success tuck Gurley Zeke Elliott even
our gobbling tomorrow we'll see what
happens to these guys but we are gonna
play a little game for people who are
newer sticks but what we like to do this
let's play some games have some fun so
today we're starting that with our
polarizing prospect over unders now
these are our betting odds we didn't
take these from Las Vegas we made these
up on our own but hopefully to be
entertaining but also give you an idea
of where we feel these players ranges
when you talk to agents and Scouts
around the league that's one thing
everyone always wants to know guys what
was the range where's this guy's range
we're gonna give that to you today and
Connor since said your brother just got
his contract we'll let you lead us off
here yeah it's my lucky day here I'm
gonna start with the most obvious
the draft but we need to talk about it
guys that is to a tongue of I Lola from
Alabama and I am setting this over-under
at four and a half and if you're sitting
there you're wondering well we know the
Bengals are taking jobber oh we know
washington is taking chase young why
would the Lions or Giants get involved
in this well the answer really here is
that somebody would have to trade up if
you're taking me under a four and a half
and guises these days go by it's
starting to feel like this one is going
to be the over you have Miami they're at
five
you have the Chargers they're at six I
don't think he gets past the Chargers
but the question is do they have a fear
of Miami taking him where they have to
go ahead I'm still gonna sit and say
take the over on four and a half or two
a number two this is Jalen Hurd's now
this might be the biggest overall riser
from the 2019 season into the draft
Jalen Hertz was a guy that eight months
ago we were wondering if he was gonna be
playing running back now we wonder if
he's gonna be the fourth or fifth
quarterback off the board in this class
I'm setting the over-under here at 50
and a half so when you look at it will
the Bears will the Steelers in the top
fifty will they pass on this guy I'm
gonna go under here which is shocking
for a lot of people when you talk about
the rise of Jalen Hertz but just what he
did in that Lincoln Reilly system this
year obviously when you're throwing the
top 15 pick CD lamb that helps you out a
little bit as well but he's improved his
mechanics it's something we've talked
about on the show a lot teams are hungry
for these mobile passers so for Jalen
Hertz going in the top 50 of this draft
is incredible and I think it's gonna
happen here guys all right let's go on
to my final one number three at the
running back position
Clyde Edwards ile air set at over/under
pick thirty nine and a half and you're
probably sitting there going well that
feels extremely random it's not you have
the Miami Dolphins at 39 you have the
Houston Texans at 40 both of those teams
need a running back so I set the bridge
in between them but the question would
Clyde Edwards a layer will DeAndre Swift
go ahead of him I think so
what about Jonathan Taylor I think so as
well it feels like him and JK Dobbins
and Cam makers are battling to be the
third running back off the board we know
Miami needs a running back we know a lot
of teams in the top 40 meter running
but will he make it past that 40th pick
I'm gonna go with the over here guys I
think we see running backs fall each and
every year I think for Clyde the glide
he's a phenomenal player a day one ready
starter but just the value of running
back and not being the top guy in this
class might see a little bit of a slide
more so than we expected what are you
guys thinking with these kana you taking
money on these bets is there these
realized cuz I'm VIN mone you like I'm
grabbing my phone right now on these so
I'm gonna say over on to it over four
and a half under fifty and a half on
jail it hurts and I would be smashing
that under on Clyde the glide over the
layer so hard right now 39 and a half I
think under I truly believe especially I
know we can't do this during the draft
but if DeAndre swift comes off that
let's say you go 16 to Atlanta which
would be a surprise but it could happen
18 in there then I think we even see
another chance for a layer to go first
round so under 39 a half for me i'm i
got glad to go ahead and i agreed with
everything you said right up until that
last thing i do think that tool we're
probably going to see that over I don't
think the Dolphins are moving I think if
they wanted to they would already do it
they'd have a trade in place we're not
seeing it I think they stay at five I
don't think the charges are gonna come
up I might be surprised if they even
take a quarterback so I'm gonna take the
over on that one with Jalen Hertz taking
that under I do think that he will be
gone by 50 the Colts at 34 right you
like options like you said Connors with
the Steelers or somebody just moving up
I you always move up to take a
quarterback you never just let one fall
to you I think the Broncos got lucky
last year by letting Drew lock do that
not many teams will but this last one
Matt I just can't see I can't see
Clyde Edwards go just don't want to
accept that he's gonna be a Kansas City
chief when this is all said I think a
good fit there and I don't want to seem
like I hate all these LSU guys I do have
a lot of questions about him but I don't
think we see a running back in round 1
which is gonna bump all of them down so
even if he's your number two running
back I don't know that he's gonna go
there I think a lot of teams are gonna
have JK Dobbins or they're gonna have
Jonathan Taylor ahead of client Edward
select well I am excited to see what
happens we are 10 days away Mel how
about your over/unders and then I'm
gonna trash them like you did I wouldn't
love a firmer Club I went a little dip
you guys had the prospects specifically
I went with positions how many position
groups do we think that will be drafted
in the first round with linebackers I'm
setting the over-under at three and a
half I think we know there are three
linebackers in this draft that are going
to be very good but are we gonna see a
fourth one sneak in there in the first
round been a lot of talk about Zack bond
then a lot of talk about Jordan Brooks
can they sneak into the first round I'm
gonna take the under on this one I don't
think we see a fourth linebackers sneak
into the first round I think we're gonna
see those three guys and then maybe in
the second round we see you're kind of
Isaiah Simmons is a lineman yeah I'm
counting him as a linebacker he's a
hybrid but I'll count him as a
linebacker for the draft and then my
next one receivers in the first round
there are a lot of talented receivers in
this draft a lot of them are gonna go
very early I'm setting the over-under at
five and a half for these receivers I
think there's a lot of them when you
look at Gerry Judy's gonna go in the
first he's gonna go very high in the
first rugs with that forty time I don't
see him slipping past two City lamb
might be gone by pick number 11 -
Conor's Jets then we're gonna get Justin
Jefferson in there I think he's a first
round lock but then we have t Higgins
where Brandon are you I don't know if we
see anymore of these receivers maybe
even a Michael Pittman slide into the
first round
Denzel Mims I'm a little bit higher in
him but I don't know if we'll see any
more receivers slide into that first
round
over/under at five and a half and then
my last one here with the corners I
think there are a lot of really good
corners in this class especially Jeff
Okuda there's probably gonna be off the
board in the top five I think the c CJ
Henderson gotta be off the board in the
top ten when you look at a CUDA he's
just too good he's gonna go early that's
gonna drive up the cost for all of these
corners in this class so I'm setting the
over-under here with the corners at four
and a half and I'll tell you guys on
these receivers I'm gonna take the under
I don't think we see that many receivers
drafted in this class I think we
probably see five in the first round
which is a lot there's a lot but it's
not though I mean a couple months ago we
were talking about maybe eight go in the
first round and that's just not the case
anymore in with the corners I'm gonna
take the over I think we see a lot of
corners maybe even up to six corners
taken in the first round Connor what do
you think of those over/under
I actually love all of them to be honest
with you and the toughest one for me out
of the bunch is your first one mellow
the linebackers even including Isaiah
Simmons I'm with you that I'm gonna go
with the under because it looks like
it's gonna be Simmons
Kenneth Murray Patrick Queen those feel
like the locks I'm curious how teams
value a guy like Zack bond that could do
a lot of different things we've heard
buzz about Jordan Brooks I don't think
those guys go into the first round
because of positions so I'll go under
three and a half with you
receivers I'm doing the same thing under
five and a half I think it's a great
class that's actually the reason it's
gonna be the over everyone's staring
each other down looking at this and
saying we'll wait till day two we can
move around day two we might even like
some of the guys that are available in
round number three so wide receivers I
think the first round we know the same
guys over and over again Henry rugs
Jerry Judy CD Lam Justin Jefferson after
that it's a bit of a wild card right now
and T Higgins did not do himself a lot
of favors throughout this draft process
and then the last one with the corners
I'm with you once again I'm gonna go
with the over we know a CUDA and CJ
Henderson
they've solidified themselves in the top
15 but you got to wonder about AJ
Terrell jaylen Johnson Christian Fulton
this is a really deep corner group and
the most important reason it's the over
mark of four and a half is because the
need is insane for all of these NFL
teams yeah and all I did mellow I think
for all three of these positions we can
see trades at the end of round one that
have a gigantic effect on how many of
these players go it's your point
linebackers if the Packers take a
receiver at 30 well that helps your
over/under lie on the receivers but I
hurt your linebackers and the same with
you know the Kansas City Chiefs and San
Francisco 49ers trained out at 31 and 32
that can affect your corner number as
well so a lot of good players I think
receivers you said this well but two
months ago people were talked about
there's a seven or eight receiver
strapped into the first round come back
to earth on that number a little bit
it's still a great receiver class but I
think what we're seeing instead is
there's going to be that rush to get the
guys it's and we can get a good receiver
in round two or three we don't feel like
we have to reach for one in the top ten
pick you're not even reach use the
assets of a top ten pick on a receiver
because I will just wait you Connors
Jets then pick at 11 a lot of talk about
maybe they just wait until the top of
the second round to get one of those
marquee wide receivers so I think that
if I had to pick I would go
I would honestly go under on all three
of these linebackers at three and a half
receivers at five and a half in corners
at five and a half that's probably the
trickiest one but now we're gonna see
four quarterbacks and five or six
offensive tackles drafted in the first
round and I'll go back here with my over
unders I went back to players instead of
positions but a nice little change up
here I'm gonna start the conversation
off with Henry rugs the wide receiver
from Alabama mr. four to nine himself
one of the fastest players that we've
ever seen perform at the NFL's got a
real for drill not a virtual combine
probably a laser timed with yeah with
Charlie cast early in the stands you
know doing the thing yeah real laser
time Henry rugs a complete wide receiver
please stop calling this guy just a
sprain or just a fast receiver by God is
he fast yes but he's also an exceptional
route runner
I put the over-under at 13 and a half 13
being significant because that's where
my San Francisco 49ers selected in the
first round so I really do think that
this is the mark where rugs do where do
we see him go under or over this spot
I'm gonna take the under on this I think
there's a good chance he is that first
receiver off the board if not I think
the Niners would snag him at 13 now how
about this one fellows we talked about
running backs earlier
DeAndre Swift from Georgia the top back
in this class according to the three of
us I set the over-under at 32 and a half
so basically do we see it running back
selected in the first round I am gonna
take the under even though as we sit
here and look at the draft board and I
try to figure out where's that first
writing back gonna come off the board it
could be 18 or 26 to the Miami Dolphins
after that what kind of guessing like
we're looking at these running backs
spots and saying man who else would do
it
there aren't many teams unless you
believe Baltimore where Tennessee would
take a running back or the Kansas City
Chiefs at 32 which again significant 32
and a half year I am gonna take the
under on jaw and race with two
exceptional three down skills reminds me
so much of Alvin Kamara with what he
does out in the backfield as well as the
speed and the bursts around the corner
we get from him and then here is maybe
the most polarizing player in the entire
draft class this Utah State quarterback
Jordan love 32 touchdowns to six
interceptions in 2018 whole staff leaves
loses his offensive line he's tied in
his running back is two receivers that
there's 30
teen pics excuse me the 2019 guys I'm
setting the over-under for Jordan Love
at fifteen and a half which 15 is the
different Rocco's they're not gonna
draft anyone there's been a lot of
conversation about teams moving up to
get Jordan love which is why I put him
here at 15 and a half I mean the guy
wore five at the Senior Bowl of the
headband he's trying so hard to be Pat
mahomes but that led to those 17 picks
this year Vito said Melo is smirking
watching this the 17 and 17 picks this
year I think a lot of people do want to
be Pat mahomes na he's got a lot of arm
talent here I'll start with Jordan love
over/under at 15 and a half I'm gonna
take the under I just are citing the
over I don't know that we're gonna see a
lot of teams wanting to move up for a
quarterback it makes me a little leery
no one's done it yet no one has moved up
to put themselves in a position to take
a quarterback so I'm gonna I'm gonna
take the over on now and I do think that
we'll see Jordan love maybe go at the
end of the first round maybe a team like
the Saints I don't think the Patriots
here in the market forward quarterback
they have a damn good one with running
back I do think we'll see what go in the
first round I think DeAndre Swift
probably the first running back off the
board
somebody will panic or the Dolphins will
use him with one of their three picks in
the first round take of running back
it's there in Henry rugs I can't see him
getting past the Las Vegas Raiders I
just think that's too good of a fit
there you have the the Jets at 11
the Raiders at 12 the Niners at 13 one
of those three teams I think gets Henry
rugs
yeah and I'll kick it off right there I
mean I am smashing the under on the
Henry rug 13 and a half I mean you got
the 49ers you got the Raiders I think
the Broncos might be sniffing around for
a trade up in this scenario
listen four to seven speed guys does not
just grow on trees every single day when
you look at what rugs can do
he is absolutely phenomenal and will be
a top what looks like 13 pick in this
trap number 2 DeAndre Swift guys for a
long time I didn't think of running back
goes in the first round of this draft
but if one is going to it will be
DeAndre swift and maybe while Twitter
and maybe this show doesn't value the
running back position as first-round
players anymore
I think the NFL does making Swift the
guys so I will go under that 32 and a
half which just means he'll make it into
the first round but the last one with
Jordan love I'm going over 15 and a half
I
the Jordan love hype died and it's not
like he really did anything it's more or
less that team's found their quarterback
replacements throughout free agency
throughout trades the market for a
quarterback like Jordan love just isn't
there in the top ten to fifteen picks
anymore so when you look at it for him
yeah we know Herbert to a borough those
guys are gonna go in the top 10 picks
but when you look at love he's gonna
wait a little longer and teams in the
back end the first round I look to
develop him not draft and start him the
joint love is definitely one the most
polarizing guys if he went five overall
to Miami we'd be a little surprised with
yeah kind of see that coming if he went
24th to the Saints yeah okay good can I
see that coming as well I think he's
gonna be QB 3 on a lot of boards if not
some people will have him over to us
some people have him over Herbert could
even be QB to one a lot of work it just
depends on we always say players like
ice cream of Liberty won and enjoy and
love polarizing big arm strong flavor
strong flavor for sure all right let's
take a little break you get to check out
the newest episode of call or nothing
just deshaun Watson Ansel answered Bill
O'Brien's phone call I don't think I
would at this point I wouldn't oh hell
no its bill oh ah Sean please don't hang
up I know you're mad about the dr.dre
tree but keep the truth to GM dust
you're the GM exactly I take the
trollwood I do what this Oh see wait
coach what are you doing hey y'all true
JJ Watt for your sourdough starter and
three rolls of doing the paper you'll do
too okay I know you're bored during
quarantine but stop making impulsive
decisions you're good scramble so we
could probably get rid of your offensive
line again
okay I'm back for good now y'all watch
time to cue ha okay let's rip up a couch
I know you're upset but richer for
DeAndre we got a second round pick
can't really evaluate the players though
right now so probably she's gonna pick
the guy who interviews best on face time
just to meet you at beef gums no we're
cool see yo what up nuke you know real
quick how do you push someone over in in
it okay here
remove coach from Chet Penn State and
Allstate you kept nice plants bro
oh no that's calamari it was good to
show I cannot wait until deshaun Watson
is Miami Dolphin I'm just starting that
rumor there's nothing to it but I hope
to god it happens speaking of deshaun
Watson being a member of the Miami
Dolphins let's play dream landing spots
mic gentlemen we each picked three
mellow you don't have to give us the
Bible on these players but your three
players and why you think that they are
a fit in this situation and I have to
serve with my favorite player in this
entire Travie class I've been talking
about Isiah Simmons not you for a very
long time now and I love his fit and I
hope to see him with the Jacksonville
Jaguars I know that he probably won't be
available at number nine overall but to
see his speed and athleticism in this
defense you bring in a guy like Joe
Schobert to play middle linebacker you
have jack as your other linebacker go
ahead and slide Isaiah Simmons in there
and let him do what he does best
absolutely everything
don't stick him in a roll and say hey go
beyond Mike linebacker let this guy roam
the field putting the slot corner he'll
put him in strong safe do you have a
need there to put him as your third
linebacker don't take him off the field
just let the man play number two spot
for me I'm gonna stay with the
linebackers because I like these guys
Kenneth Murray to the Ravens is a pick
that I'm going to be making in a lot of
my mock drafts they need a middle
linebacker do you like a player from
Oklahoma
I got a okay so it's happened three
things in my life
Adrian Peterson couldn't wait for him to
graduate was scared of him and then
these two guys this year see Neil and
Kenneth worry I really like both of them
and I think that was Murray he's a great
fit for what the Ravens need and he's
gonna be the ass kicker at middle
linebacker who comes in he's a vocal
leader he's also a tackling machine I
think that he can be very good an
immediate starter for that team and then
my last guy you know or gross mottos is
another guy with the Vikings
I forgot the same on one of our podcast
it still fits I like what he can do
opposite at the end getting after the
quarterback you got some pretty good
quarterbacks up there and you got
Mitchell try Biscay - I think you still
have to get after the boy if you
NFC you have to be able to get after
guys like Drew Brees and Carson Wentz
Minnesota they keep finding ways to win
in the playoffs in advance you have to
be able to beat drew Brees though to get
there who gets to wear 99 Danielle
hunter or Grossmont I think we're you
know the answer to that one right I know
there's a Tom Brady Chris Godwin
situation I actually love grouse monos
as well that's one of my favorite fits
in this draft Kenneth Murray to
Baltimore it some guys you watch them
you're like this man was born to play
this for this team and that is Kenneth
Murray to the Ravens they it was like
miko hartmann last year like we knew
where he was gonna end up even before he
ended up there now Connor I know that
you put your Jets on this list you have
to do it who are your three dream
landing spots for this year's draft of
course I did guys this is the stick to
football live debut the crappy Jets are
definitely sneaking in on the action
here and Melo I love the all defensive
dreams good spots I yeah I thought you
nailed them all right number one here
I'm gonna stick with the defense and I'm
not gonna go with the Jets I'm gonna go
with the New York Giants and that is
Antoine Winfield jr. when you look at
this Giants defense they just lack an
identity right now and you have to
wonder since Landon Collins left who is
the guy who's the playmaker who's
getting the ball grow peppers yeah
that's not it so when you look at
Webster junior I mean phenomenal hands
he could hit yeah no no joke the guy can
absolutely light people up
I love his game guys he can cover in the
slot he can play too deep he could play
single high could really do anything you
need him to do but his best work comes
down in the box and most importantly in
the second round this would upgrade the
Giants defense right away
number two yeah it's time for the New
York Jets and let's get Sam there
Arnold's old friend back it's Michael
Pittman jr. and you're gonna recognize
these names this year Winfield Pittman
it's time for the next era this guy is
they go up and get the football kind of
player the Jets have nobody like that
right now and and for Pittman yes
there's a relationship already there
with Sam Donald obviously when darn 'old
the year he was drafted Pittman was a
sophomore receiver and a productive one
at that so the chemistry is there but
this guy's a good athlete he's tough he
has some of the best hands in the entire
draft and I love you heard
the New York Jets wide receiver core the
only name you might recognize at this
point is Jameson Crowder unless you're
really relying on Prashad Pearman to be
the guy so in the second round again
now the Jets get help now I'm gonna go
to the third round here and let's talk
about the Buffalo Bills Brandon bean has
done a phenomenal job building this
football team and most importantly
attacking value in the draft and one of
the ways he did that recently is by
getting motor Singletary for their
backfield last year a pair with Frank
Gore no more Frank Gore now you need
another guy let's get Zack Moss from
Utah the power back the guy that makes
people miss the guy that runs through
people so for the bills here you went
out and traded first Stephane Diggs you
have a really good wide receiver Trillo
you have somebody you really like and
Devin Singletary in the backfield but
he's a 1b kind of guy
now get his 1a in Zach Moss this Bills
team with Tom Brady gone and it pains me
to say it they're ready to take over the
AFC East and they might have an exciting
offense to watch I would absolutely love
Zach Moss behind that Buffalo offensive
line because they're just Mahler's and
they need someone like him who is a
little bit of a throwback road grader I
was waiting for you to pick a third guy
whose dad played in the NFL you know
like you got Michael Pippen
there's got to be something if there
were a fourth New York team apparently
you would have hit with it because you
go Giants Jets Bills
I like your fit though Antoine Winfield
I just want to remind everyone who's
watching or listening this guy didn't
win the four per Ward last year I don't
know how the hell that happens but he
didn't but he has a do-it-all safety and
if it weren't for injuries and if you
were a little bit bigger I think he'd be
a lot for a top 15 pick even at safety I
love to fit there Giants need somebody
that's kind of their identity on defense
and Michael Pittman is the perfect fit
force and Arnold in the Jets they should
definitely target him in the second
round and Sam Donald's should target him
often he needs a big receiver they can
go up and make plays and that's exactly
what Michael Pittman is and then of
course Zach Moss bring in that a little
bit of thunder with your lightning that
you already have it running back it just
fits all right here is the the ultimate
list now they save the best for last
fella
the fourth New York team will that's the
Philadelphia Eagles actually they're
basically a New York team and I'm going
with just two jumps in here I got
man out of left Co happy give you a
silky smooth wide receiver who does not
drop the ball sorry Nelson a galore he
could play in the slot he could play out
wide we saw the production that my man
had when Joe Brady decided to actually
throw the football at LSU something they
haven't done since Jamarcus freaking
russell was there but jefferson might be
a smaller guy before for three speed and
he was actually very very good in the
red zone something that you don't see a
lot with smaller wide receivers I think
in a normal draft class Justin Jefferson
would be the top wide receiver it just
so happens this is a historic season so
he's a little bit lower on the board but
I absolutely love his style of play give
Carson Wentz a reliable threat no shade
to my guy al Sean a reliable threat who
can make things happen after the catch
now the Atlanta Falcons were Dan Quinn
coach before College Lorna Florida there
we go so he goes back around clarinha
back to Florida to Gainesville to get CJ
Henderson six-foot one for three speed
he's feisty in coverage down the field
don't care that he doesn't tackle Deion
Sanders didn't either when he played for
the Falcons he turned out okay
CJ Henderson I absolutely love his game
he's a top 15 player for me what he does
down the field think I wish I was a good
tackle so people on Twitter can get off
me yeah look that was too easy tackle
see I don't know where the talks coming
from it's what he does down the field
though I actually think he got bored in
coverage at times this year which is why
we saw him getting beat a little bit he
likes to bait quarterbacks into mistakes
with his speed I think he's gonna be a
very very good player at the next level
and fills a gigantic need for the
Atlanta Falcons now that Desmond Trufant
is a member of the Detroit Lions and
unfortunately I loved Trufant
just a guy who got a little bit too old
so CJ Henderson if he's there at 16 make
the pick Thomas Dimitrov and from my
last one wide receiver one in this
classroom me Jerry Judy from Alabama he
went wired a wire is the top wide
receiver in this class and I'm gonna
give him sorry Melo to the Denver
Broncos because that offense is fixing
to be electric as we like to say here in
Missouri you got Melvin Gordon in the
backfield you drafted into a phantom
Reisner last year to go with rookie
quarterback drew lock oh and you have
Courtland Sutton one of the best young
receivers in football now what I love
about this is Judy doesn't have to be
your number one he can play some in the
slot where he's gonna get free releases
he's going to
less attention from safeties because
this is a well rounded offense you see
what he does tracking the ball down the
field he was excellent in the red zone
at 6-foot 193 pounds tracks the ball
well it's not he's not the biggest guy
he's not the fastest guy you're not
gonna see it when you look at the stat
sheet all the time but what he does is a
route runner explosive footwork
imbalance absolutely love Jerry Judy
yeah I really like those fits and go
back to Justin Jefferson like you said
if this is a normal draft class he's the
top receiver in it I think going back to
last year he would have been the number
one far and away we see her in that
class but this one's loaded with so much
talent even going back to guys like T
Higgins I think in a normal year we
would see them rise up so the Eagles
obviously they have to get somebody that
can catch the ball cuz Nelson Aguilar
struggled last year and then DeSean
Jackson is he gonna stay healthy I don't
know he's getting old I'll shine can he
separate probably not you need a
receiver I think you can maybe wait till
round two but if Justin Jefferson is
there I think you have to take him if
he's drafted before the Eagles maybe
we're out wait but if Justin Jefferson
is there for the Eagles they should
definitely take him and I think when you
write about other - I mean the Justin
Jefferson one is a no-brainer but CJ
Anderson to the Falcons that team needs
a corner they put a lot of money and
resources into that front seven guys he
added Dante Fowler yeah obviously got
Grady Jarrett there so I thought you
actually hit it out of the park we give
you a lot of crap Matt about you you
know who being the best of these things
but yet a good list thank you and I
didn't have to use sources so whoever
had that prep bit on Twitter you lost
there's one right I don't know that one
counts okay let's take a break and go to
my favorite cartoon this is the one my
son watches before school now gridiron
Heights
we got a supercut of Papa Bill rivers he
was six foot five with a bow tie and a
face that was downright punch there with
you step up centers hosted at flippin
soccer practice nobody respects us with
a GT front motors for Nancy Wow car
Helen kiss my tuchus
I'm staying here yeah okay let's leave
hey if y'all just behave I'll buy LG
french fries the folk
fudge the offseason I won't break it
football win this for me son throw balls
and memories that's all you got
watch it Brady stop me from being a GTA
down geez get it clown not gonna put to
get me San Diego
stole my can't frickin believe we gotta
save the GD day again
okay well Larry's clearly hall-of-famer
Riley has the Rings that fails
consistency right yeah Oh everyone Dogon
loves you hey 2040 lot yeah I'm a
hall-of-famer see my friend wolf is a
charger anyone anyone who can rock a
bolo tie and force your way out of San
Diego and La as a hall-of-famer in my
book I know he's one of Melos favorite
quarterback saw time be fun to see what
old Papa Phil and his ducklings do in
Indianapolis then that new Colts logo
actually I like it I don't know if you
guys saw today it's been one of the few
like logo uniform releases that I
actually kind of liked and I I did hear
today the Chargers are doing theirs
Wednesday
I think the Browns have went out this
week too yeah everyone's doing it except
for us we like our logo we're sticking
with it we just have a show now in
addition to a podcast right when we
close out every edition of six people
but we do fan questions it's called
draft on dress we have three awesome
questions that were submitted through
Twitter if you want to do that just hash
tag draft on draft first one up from
Tyler for Ness why do Florida defensive
backs bust in the NFL at such a high
rate Tyler my belief is because they
don't have to they haven't learned
technique a lot in college these
athletes Florida's recruiting these
track stars Vernon Hargreaves do guys
like that they just throw them out there
as true freshmen they play and they
don't develop or did not develop I think
the new coaching staffs can be better at
that but that's a huge complaint of line
with you know I've missed on some
Florida corners over the years and it's
because guys like that they're just not
developed well everybody's missed on the
Florida corners and I think they just
kind of get a reputation there for a
while although we're a member of the DB
you conversation so a lot of it was you
know people scouting the helman seeing a
athlete like T's taper out there at
corner and say no big corner athletic
from Florida he's gonna be good we used
to do it with Alabama corners for a long
time right and then they were busting so
I think it's just Florida doing their
their time they're gonna bust a little
bit and I think we're maybe getting out
of it with CJ and you don't know what
Humphrey I think CJ Henderson's gonna be
that guy I think he's a safe picket
corner yeah when you look at the
problems across the board guys it feels
like they've all been a little different
tees taper couldn't run if York and take
note of this if you're a corner running
in the four sixes you're probably not
gonna pan out just not a lot of guys do
it's as simple as that he couldn't run
Quincy Wilson while he was a four or
five four guy Matt already said it the
technique was a problem and it's not
great speed his play speed wasn't great
but the technique was an issue and then
when you look at Vernon Hargreaves size
was an issue I think injuries and
penalties so I like that you brought up
CJ Henderson Melo
that when you evaluate him because you
know obviously you need to evaluate the
player not the helmet here Henderson he
can run he was in the four threes pretty
pretty good the film was good I think
the technique is much more advanced than
these guys I think his instincts are
lacking just a little bit but there's a
reason he's a first rounder while the
other guys not Hargreaves but you know
Wilson and tease those guys were day two
players the whole time and his ball
skills at finding the football and
making a play on the ball I think we're
probably the best even ahead of Jeff
Okuda yep and it definitely has the
speed that teams look for Richie
Bradshaw wants to know we've heard for a
while that team's view Brandon IU as a
better prospect than Nikhil Harry last
year what separates the two and for me
Melo I think the Kerr hair was your
number one receiver last year I want to
say he was number two or number three
for me the difference for me is
separation and when you evaluate wide
receivers a lot of times you say okay
you can separate three ways speed routes
or size I really thought Nikhil Harry
would be able to separate with size and
routes we didn't see him do that in a
rookie season that was mostly lost to
injury with Brandon I you immediate
ability to separate with speed and
quickness off the line yeah those are
explosive plays you can see it when he
runs and we're talking about I you I
think that is what separates them I
still think Nikhil Harry is a better
prospect I think that New England system
is very
hard to learn remember we saw a guy in
otro Cinco go to New England and
everybody thought he was gonna be a Pro
Bowler could figure out to playbook so I
think we need to maybe pump the brakes
on Nicky Larry or maybe I'm just a
little bit biased because he was my
number one receiver but I think that he
can come around and have a good year
again
I still have Nikhil Harry ahead of
Brandon Ayub yeah I don't think the gap
is that big here guys of course we love
seeing ioq speed we love seeing his
routes ability with the ball in the
hands is absolutely phenomenal compared
to kill Harry but in the red zone and
just physically dominating DB's Harry
was a much better player so when you
look at it they're very different
players in very different draft classes
but at the end of the day just because
he was hurt let's not forget how good
Nikhil Harry was as a prospect at one
time and I think it's easy because I can
come in and play in the slot he's gonna
get those little dump off passes and
he's gonna play 800 yards well here in
Washington basically and he returns you
well so I like what Melo said let's do
it Nikhil Harry looks like with Jairus
did I'm a quarterback at my belly like
definitely right right Pro Bowl both of
them yeah all right your cheek rubble
you gonna put some money on that no no
pending anything right whoever again
rice last question he saw a rumor online
gentlemen who the Falcons are
considering trading up for a quarterback
is this a smoke screen or could this
actually happen ty buddy
anything can happen can't see it yeah
hey I just Falcons the Atlanta ones yeah
Falcons yep no I made me think I read it
wrong or said well says the Falcons yep
I can't see it it says foul I think
that's the question I don't see it I
think Thomas Dimitrov at this point it's
just seeing what he could do to stir the
pot when we got to spend time with him
at the Senior Bowl he was dying to sneak
in that they're a team that could trade
up or down so I think there's all kind
of smoke around Atlanta I didn't see a
Matt Ryan drop off last year that would
indicate something like this no you like
got hurt for the first time in his
career he's not he's 34 years old still
relatively young will be 35 when the
season starts I do think they should
draft a backup this year in the later
rounds somebody can develop like a Cole
McDonald like Anthony Gorn from
Washington State draft somebody you can
develop a little bit
I cannot see the mortgaging the futures
Jim what would they trade 16 overall you
would have to train so many future years
traps it would be the Redskins trading
up for our g3 at this point yeah I try
to get something like I don't see the
Falcons doing it not yet in the next 2-3
years maybe but I still think there's a
lot of good football left in Matt Ryan
at least good enough you still have
Julio Jones to throw to and maybe we see
a bounce-back year from a Todd Gurley I
think this is a lot of a smoke screen
maybe somebody trades in front of us
tries to get up there and we see another
guy fall I mean if Jordan love gets
drafted that pushes Javon kianlawl down
pushes maybe CJ Henderson down and then
the Falcons get the guy they want went
all along no they didn't want a
cornerback and we're seeing this light
raisi right now here guys I mean when
you look at it right now the smoke
around teams - for other players to fall
it's naturally gonna happen so I think
Atlanta they understand that 16 and we
talked about this with Dallas a lot at
17 it feels like the breaking point of
the draft you're hoping that Javon
Kinlaw or Kayla Vaughn chase on or CJ
Henderson although it feels like those
days are long gone make it to that spot
yeah it is it's lying season as we say
ten days before the NFL Draft and that
is our show our first show in the
Bleacher Report app hopefully you guys
enjoyed stick to football live if you're
a podcast listener Connor has an awesome
interview with Darnay holds for UCLA
that you can hear after this so thank
you everyone for hanging out and we'll
talk to you guys on Wednesday afternoon
right here at 5 p.m. Eastern Time and of
course wherever you listen to show
Spotify at the podcasts wherever it
might be follow us on Twitter at 6
football and make sure you download that
Bleacher Report app from ello and Connor
this is Matt we'll see you all real soon
[Music]
[Music]